Today's whole show came out of this thing that we heard that politicians said. And we wondered-- is that true? Like, was he right? And the answer set us on this eight-month journey, where at some point, like the best journeys, I think, we forgot what the original reason was that we set out. And we just started to learn all kinds of things that we had never imagined back at the beginning.
今天整个节目源于我们听到政客们说的一件事。我们不禁好奇——那是真的吗？比如，他是对的吗？这个答案让我们踏上了一段长达八个月的旅程，而在旅途中的某个时刻，就像所有最好的旅程一样，我想，我们忘记了当初出发的初衷。我们开始学习各种在起初完全无法想象的事情。
Where we ended up was Albertville, Alabama, a mountain town in the northern part of the state, a town that went through a huge change in population very quickly. Back in 1990, Albertville was 98% white. Then it got a flood of outsiders, mostly from Mexico, documented and undocumented immigrants. So many people that after just 20 years the all-white town was more than 1/4 Latino. Basically, Albertville was around 15,000 people. It got another 6,000. Most of them came to work in the poultry processing plants in town.
我们最终到达的地方是阿拉巴马州的阿尔伯特维尔，这是该州北部的一个山区小镇，这个小镇在短时间内经历了巨大的人口变迁。回到1990年，阿尔伯特维尔98%的人口是白人。随后，大批外来者涌入，主要是来自墨西哥的合法和非法移民。人数之多，以至于仅仅20年后，这个全白人小镇就有超过1/4是拉丁裔。基本上，阿尔伯特维尔原有约15,000人，又增加了6,000人。他们大多数来到镇上的家禽加工厂工作。
And one nice thing about Albertville-- if you want to understand what really happened there during the town's big change-- it's small enough that you can just show up. Like, everybody's still kind of right there. Like, if you walk into one of the poultry plants and ask, who was the first Latino worker to show up here? They actually know. One of my coworkers, Miki Meek, did just that.
阿尔伯特维尔有一点很好——如果你想了解在这个小镇发生巨大变化期间究竟发生了什么——它足够小，你可以直接过去看看。每个人都还住在那里。比如，如果你走进一家禽加工厂问，第一个来到这里的拉丁裔工人是谁？他们实际上知道。我的同事米基·米克（Miki Meek）就做了这件事。
Do you remember who one of the first immigrants was to work at the plant?
你记得第一个在工厂工作的移民是谁吗？
Gregorio or something like that.
格雷戈里奥（Gregorio）之类的名字。
Gregoria, Gregoria something. I don't know his last name. They called him ravioli.
格雷戈里亚，格雷戈里亚什么来着。我不知道他的姓。他们管他叫“饺子”（ravioli）。
They call him ravioli? Why ravioli?
他们管他叫“饺子”？为什么叫“饺子”？
I don't know. Cause his name's hard to pronounce, I guess.
我不知道。我想是因为他的名字很难发音吧。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And he couldn't speak any English. Kind of shy, you know? And his name was Gregoriola, and he's still at the plant.
而且他不会说英语。有点害羞，你知道吗？他的名字叫格雷戈里奥拉（Gregoriola），他现在还在那家工厂工作。
We did locate this mythical Latino chicken plant Neil Armstrong, Gregorio. And he is kind of shy, wouldn't make eye contact, mumbled. And after we made three visits to his house, he finally got rid of us by fobbing us off on his uncle.
我们确实找到了这位传说中的拉丁裔鸡肉加工厂“尼尔·阿姆斯特朗”——格雷戈里奥。他确实有点害羞，不愿与人目光接触，说话含糊不清。在我们三次拜访他家之后，他终于通过让他叔叔来应付我们，打发走了我们。
Gregorio? I mean, he not talk to nobody, too quiet.
格雷戈里奥？我是说，他不跟任何人说话，太安静了。
He's too quiet?
他太安静了？
Yeah.
是的。
His uncle, Fernando Martinez, is the opposite of shy-- extroverted, super-friendly, an amateur guitarist and singer with a gigantic mustache and shaggy hair that make him look like the 1970s country rock star, Freddy Fender. Fernando and Gregorio came to the chicken plants in Albertville right when this all began, sometime around 1991, neither can remember exactly. And one of the people Fernando met was Pat. Now in her 60s and eligible for retirement, she's still working, still tough, always on the move.
他的叔叔费尔南多·马丁内斯（Fernando Martinez）与害羞正好相反——外向、超级友好，是个业余吉他手和歌手，留着巨大的胡子，头发蓬松，让他看起来像1970年代的乡村摇滚明星弗雷迪·芬德（Freddy Fender）。费尔南多和格雷戈里奥大约在1991年这一切开始的时候来到阿尔伯特维尔的鸡肉加工厂，没人记得确切时间。费尔南多认识的人之一是帕特（Pat）。如今她已60多岁，达到了退休年龄，但她仍在工作，依然坚韧，总是闲不下来。
That's what I like about it. I go to work. I clock in at 15 to 4:00 every morning. I'm moving. I'm moving.
这就是我喜欢它的地方。我去工作。我每天清晨4点差15分打卡。我在动。我一直在动。
She's been at her plant for 44 years and has held just about every job there. Pulled out guts and lungs. Ran the box machine. Sawed chickens into nine-piece meals for KFC. She befriended Fernando and Gregorio.
她在她的工厂工作了44年，几乎做过那里的每一份工作。处理过内脏和肺。操作过装箱机。为了肯德基把鸡肉锯成九块装。她和费尔南多以及格雷戈里奥成了朋友。
Before Greg, had you ever met a Latino before?
在格雷格之前，你以前见过拉丁裔吗？
No. He was really my first. I kind of-- I wasn't too sure.
没有。他真的是我的第一个。我有点……我不太确定。
Basically, Fernando just sat down at Pat's lunch table one day, and they started talking tentatively. Here's Fernando speaking through an interpreter. It's easier for him than being interviewed in English.
基本上，费尔南多有一天只是坐在了帕特的午餐桌旁，他们开始试探性地交谈。这是通过翻译说话的费尔南多。对他来说，这比用英语接受采访更容易。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语交谈]
And from then on, I sat with her every day.
从那时起，我每天都和她坐在一起。
What would you guys talk about? How did you communicate?
你们会聊些什么？你们是如何交流的？
Yeah, you know, [SPEAKING SPANISH]
是的，你知道，[西班牙语交谈]
You're never really talking about work. They would ask me if I had a girlfriend or a wife.
你从来不是真的在谈论工作。他们会问我是否有男朋友或丈夫。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语交谈]
Hey, Fernando, you got any kids? And I said, who knows?
嘿，费尔南多，你有孩子吗？我说，谁知道呢？
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语交谈]
And then we started laughing together.
然后我们就开始一起笑。
But then in a few years at this plant, things would get pretty tense and suspicious between the Mexican workers and the local workers, and things would get pretty ugly in town too. But back then at the very beginning, newcomers were a novelty, not a threat. It wasn't hard to get along.
但几年后，在这家工厂里，墨西哥工人和当地工人之间的关系变得非常紧张和猜忌，镇上的情况也变得相当糟糕。但在那时，在最开始，新来者是一种新奇事物，而不是威胁。相处并不难。
And we were just sitting there one day, and we were talking. And he said, Patricia? I said, what? I said, what did you call me? He said, that's your name in Spanish. My name is Patricia, but he said Pa-tree-cee-ah. And I thought, God, that sounds so pretty. I've never liked my name. But ever since he said it, I've liked my name.
有一天我们坐在一起聊天。他说，帕特里夏（Patricia）？我说，什么？我说，你叫我什么？他说，那是你的名字在西班牙语里的读音。我的名字是帕特里夏，但他说是Pa-tree-cee-ah。我想，天哪，听起来真美。我从来不喜欢我的名字。但自从他那样说之后，我就喜欢上我的名字了。
(LAUGHING) Oh, really?
[笑] 哦，真的吗？
Yep. It's cornball. I know. But he said Patricia.
是的。这很老套。我知道。但他说了帕特里夏。
You thought that was beautiful.
你觉得那很美。
Yeah, it did. It sounded so beautiful.
是的，确实。听起来太美了。
Patricia. Patricia.
帕特里夏。帕特里夏。
OK, so we went to Albertville because of something that a politician said, and the politician was Jeff Sessions, longtime Alabama senator, currently President Trump's Attorney General. It's Sessions' views on immigration that have become administration policy. The administration has proposed cutting the number of immigrants who come into this country each year in half.
好吧，所以我们去阿尔伯特维尔是因为一位政客说的话，那位政客是杰夫·塞申斯（Jeff Sessions），阿拉巴马州的长期参议员，现任特朗普总统的司法部长。正是塞申斯在移民问题上的观点成为了政府的政策。政府提议将每年进入这个国家的移民人数减少一半。
And it especially targets the kind of workers who arrived in Albertville-- low-wage, unskilled workers who don't speak English. That's something Sessions has been pushing for for over a decade, and it's not a coincidence that those are the workers most targeted. A longtime ally of his in Washington on the immigration issue, Roy Beck, the founder of a group called NumbersUSA, has known Sessions since the '90s, says--
而且它特别针对像到达阿尔伯特维尔的那类工人——低工资、非技术工人，不会说英语。那是塞申斯十多年来一直推动的事情，这些工人成为主要目标并非巧合。他在华盛顿移民问题上的长期盟友，NumbersUSA组织的创始人罗伊·贝克（Roy Beck），从90年代就认识塞申斯，他说——
I really doubt that he would have made immigration his signature issue if not for his experience with the poultry plants in Alabama.
我真心怀疑，如果不是因为他在阿拉巴马州家禽加工厂的经历，他是否会把移民作为他的标志性议题。
We wanted to see what Sessions saw, and we went looking for a poultry town that got a ton of immigrants. And in Alabama, the poster town for that is Albertville. Jeff Sessions has visited Albertville. He's spoken there. Met up with the mayor and residents about the immigrants who arrived. And whatever it is that Sessions saw in those Alabama chicken plants, it sent him down the road to some very strong positions. He declined our request for an interview, but here he is on the floor of the Senate in 2007.
我们想看看塞申斯所看到的一切，于是我们寻找了一个接收了大量移民的家禽加工城镇。在阿拉巴马州，这方面的典型城镇就是阿尔伯特维尔。杰夫·塞申斯访问过阿尔伯特维尔。他在那里发表过演讲。与市长和居民见过面，谈论到达那里的移民。无论塞申斯在那些阿拉巴马州的鸡肉加工厂看到了什么，这都让他走向了一些非常强硬的立场。他拒绝了我们的采访请求，但这是他在2007年参议院会议上的发言。
And big greedy businesses who hire illegal workers, and hiring those numbers by the tens or hundreds of thousands, will pull down the wages of American citizens. Why would we do that? Why don't we take care of our American workers?
那些贪婪的大企业雇佣非法劳工，雇佣成千上万的人，会拉低美国公民的工资。我们为什么要那样做？我们为什么不照顾我们的美国工人？
This is him in 2014.
这是他在2014年的发言。
I talked to a business person recently about a factory that they have. The work sounded pretty good to me, and he wants to bring in foreign workers to Alabama. Well, we've got unemployment in Alabama. We've got people on unemployment insurance. We've got people on welfare, and food stamps, and assistance that need to be taking those jobs.
我最近和一位企业主谈论过他们的一家工厂。那份工作听起来对我来说相当不错，但他想从国外引进工人到阿拉巴马州。好吧，阿拉巴马州有失业问题。我们有靠失业保险生活的人。我们有需要靠福利、食品券和援助才能维持生计的人，他们需要得到那些工作。
The former state senator, Scott Beason, who helped write Alabama's landmark 2011 self-deportation bill, once said, quote, "if you don't believe illegal immigration will destroy a community, go and check out parts of Alabama around Albertville." So was Albertville destroyed? Are Beason and Jeff Sessions right? To figure out the answer, we've interviewed more than 100 people, workers and managers at the poultry plants, politicians, law enforcement, documented and undocumented immigrants, kids of immigrants who grew up in town, older white residents who hated the changes.
前州参议员斯科特·比森（Scott Beason），曾帮助撰写了阿拉巴马州2011年具有里程碑意义的“自我遣返”法案，他曾说：“如果你不相信非法移民会摧毁一个社区，去看看阿尔伯特维尔周围的阿拉巴马州部分地区。”那么阿尔伯特维尔被摧毁了吗？比森和杰夫·塞申斯是对的吗？为了找出答案，我们采访了100多人，包括家禽加工厂的工人和经理、政客、执法人员、合法和非法移民、在镇上长大的移民子女、痛恨这些变化的年长白人居民。
We also had an economist look at what happened to wages and to jobs. Another economist estimated what it cost the town to pay for schools and public services for the newcomers. This is an issue where one side says that immigrants are an awful threat, stealing jobs, committing crimes, costing taxpayers. And the other side says that they're the exact opposite, the very source of our strength as a country, boosting the economy, adding diversity.
我们还请了一位经济学家研究了工资和就业发生了什么变化。另一位经济学家估计了该镇为新来者支付学校和公共服务所花费的成本。这是一个一边说移民是可怕的威胁，偷走工作、犯罪、给纳税人增加负担；而另一边说他们恰恰相反，是我们国家力量的源泉，促进经济、增加多样性的议题。
And here at our show we thought for once, rather than hash over those familiar arguments, let's just go to a place where immigration has happened and talk in a factual way about what the hell actually occurs when lots of low-wage, low-skill workers arrive from another country. Like, what's that actually do to everyone's lives? What we learned, from WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life, and I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
在我们这个节目，我们认为这一次，与其重复那些熟悉的争论，不如去一个移民实际发生的地方，以事实的方式谈论当大量低工资、低技能的工人从另一个国家到达时，到底会发生什么。比如，这实际上对每个人的生活产生了什么影响？我们所了解到的，来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，《美国生活》（This American Life），我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。请继续关注我们。
So on today's show, we're going to talk about the effect that the newcomers had on jobs. So all the action's going to be inside the chicken plants. Next, we're going to take up what happened in town-- politics, schools, taxes, crime, all that.
所以在今天的节目中，我们将讨论新来者对就业的影响。所有的行动都将发生在鸡肉加工厂内。接下来，我们将讨论镇上发生的事情——政治、学校、税收、犯罪，所有这些。
My co-host for both shows is going to be my coworker, Miki Meek. She and I have been traveling down to Albertville with our colleague, Lilly Sullivan, many trips over the last eight months. Miki's the one who spent a lot of time talking to poultry workers. And Miki, the changes were a shock to longtime workers, right?
这两个节目的联合主持人将是我的同事米基·米克。过去八个月里，她和我与我们的同事莉莉·沙利文（Lilly Sullivan）多次前往阿尔伯特维尔。米基花了很多时间与家禽加工厂工人交谈。米基，这些变化对长期工人来说是一个冲击，对吧？
So yeah, because the chicken plants were pretty much built for them. This happened right after World War II, when the state of Alabama realized it needed a new economic strategy. Cotton and corn weren't bringing in much for small farmers anymore. They wanted to keep people in jobs. So they decided to get the state into poultry production.
是的，因为鸡肉加工厂几乎是为他们而建的。这发生在第二次世界大战之后，当时阿拉巴马州意识到它需要一种新的经济战略。棉花和玉米已经不能给小农户带来多少收益了。他们想让人有工作。所以他们决定让该州进入家禽生产行业。
They wanted to stick a plant up north to kill and process chickens, and they let different towns compete for it. Albertville won and built the first plant near the middle of town, right next door to the high school. Many more plants joined later. And now poultry companies are the biggest employers in town. Poultry is also the biggest agribusiness in Alabama, almost 10% of the state's economy, a billion chickens every year.
他们想在北部建一家工厂来屠宰和加工鸡肉，并让不同的城镇竞标。阿尔伯特维尔赢了，并在镇中心附近建了第一家工厂，就在高中隔壁。后来又加入了更多工厂。现在家禽公司是镇上最大的雇主。家禽业也是阿拉巴马州最大的农业综合企业，每年处理十亿只鸡。
Pat, who you heard earlier, she and her father were exactly the workers who these plants were built for. Growing up, she worked in the cotton fields with her dad. Then he got a job in a plant, and she followed him in soon after. She started as a giblet wrapper.
你刚才听到的帕特，她和她的父亲正是这些工厂为之建造的工人。在成长过程中，她和父亲在棉田里工作。后来他得到了一份工厂的工作，她不久后也跟着进了工厂。她最初是做内脏包装工。
1973, August the 13th.
1973年8月13日。
How do you still remember the date?
你怎么还记得那个日期？
It's just easy. [LAUGHTER] It's just August the 13, 1973. And you got to remember, this was the early years.
这很容易。[笑声] 就是1973年8月13日。你得记住，那是早期。
OK, so what does that mean?
好吧，那是什么意思？
The early years, it was like a kind of unit. Same 18 ladies on that wrapping table, older, hard-working people that come out of the fields. It was family. It was family.
早期，那就像一个团队。在那个包装台上同样的18位女士，年长、努力工作的人，都是从田里出来的。那是家庭。那是家庭。
Everybody knew the chicken plant was good pay, benefits, retirement, a decent job if you didn't finish high school. And that's mostly who took the jobs. Pat dropped out after ninth grade, got married, and had two kids. She took a job at the plant because--
每个人都知道鸡肉加工厂待遇不错、有福利、退休金，如果你没有完成高中学业，这是一份体面的工作。这就是大多数接受这些工作的人。帕特在九年级辍学，结婚，生了两个孩子。她接受了工厂的工作是因为——
I wanted to buy a house. And we penny-pinched, penny-pinched till we had our down payment.
我想买一栋房子。我们省吃俭用，省吃俭用，直到我们有了首付。
And so you got your house?
所以你买了你的房子？
And we got this house.
我们买了这栋房子。
And it's this house right here?
就是这栋房子吗？
This same house that we live in right now.
就是我们现在住的这栋房子。
One unusual thing about these poultry plants-- by the late 1980s, there were long term workers at the plants, for sure. But turnover was so high in the plants it's like you could always show up and just expect to get a job. You fall on tough times, you need to pick up money for a family emergency, you knew the plant was there.
关于这些家禽加工厂有一件不同寻常的事情——到1980年代末，工厂里确实有长期工人。但工厂的人员流动率非常高，以至于你总是可以去那里指望得到一份工作。你陷入困境，需要赚点钱应对家庭紧急情况，你知道工厂就在那里。
The plants were like a public utility in that way. The head of HR at one of the plants, Tom Howell, said that when he started at Wayne Farms back in 1990-- this is before tons of Mexican workers showed up-- it was common to hire the same person five or six times in the same year.
工厂在那种意义上就像一个公共事业设施。其中一家工厂的人力资源主管汤姆·豪威尔（Tom Howell）说，当他在1990年刚进入Wayne Farms时——那是在大量墨西哥工人出现之前——一年雇佣同一个人五六次是很常见的。
Well, they'd use the mirror test.
嗯，他们会用镜子测试。
And the mirror test is what?
镜子测试是什么？
I'm surprised you don't know what the mirror test is. That's pretty simple. You just stick it under a person's nose, and if they fog that mirror up, you know they're breathing. So you put them to work.
我很惊讶你不知道什么是镜子测试。这很简单。你只是把它放在一个人的鼻子下，如果他们让镜子起了雾，你就知道他们在呼吸。所以你就让他们工作。
People joked that you could quit one plant in the morning and get hired by another plant in the afternoon. And the first real change to that came in the mid-1990s. By then, there was a rapid and steady stream of Mexican workers arriving, hundreds of them, mostly men, mostly here without their families.
人们开玩笑说，你可以在早上辞掉一家工厂的工作，下午被另一家工厂雇佣。第一次真正的改变发生在1990年代中期。到那时，墨西哥工人开始快速而稳定地涌入，几百人，主要是男性，大多没有带家人。
One of Pat's good friends is an especially helpful witness to what happened in their plant. This is a woman everybody calls Miss Martha-- wavy brown and gray hair and glasses. She's been there since the '70s and works at the supply window, which means she talks to just about everyone. They all have to go to her window to pick up gloves and aprons.
帕特的好朋友之一是当时工厂发生的事情的一个特别有用的见证人。这就是大家都叫玛莎女士（Miss Martha）的女性——有着波浪形的棕灰头发和眼镜。她从70年代就在那里工作，在供应窗口工作，这意味着她几乎和每个人都会说话。他们都必须去她的窗口领取手套和围裙。
Oh, it's the little gossip window, I guess. People just want to come up and talk, and I'm a good listener. So I listen to them.
噢，我想那是小八卦窗口吧。人们只是想过来聊天，而我是一个很好的倾听者。所以我听他们说。
She says she likes to play 20 Questions at the window. I made her tell me some of the questions.
她说她喜欢在窗口玩“二十个问题”。我让她告诉我一些问题。
How many kids you got? How far do you work from here? Your family live with you? You know, little simple questions that you lead up.
你有几个孩子？你住得离这儿多远？你的家人和你住在一起吗？你知道，你可以引导的小问题。
And then when you know them a little bit better, what can you move on to?
然后当你更了解他们一点后，你可以问什么？
Got a girlfriend? You married? How much money you got in the bank?
有女朋友吗？你结婚了吗？你银行里有多少钱？
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And most of the time they'll tell me what they've done.
大多数时候他们会告诉我他们做过什么。
She says when the Latino workers showed up, they and the local workers were kind of just thrown together in this fast-paced industrial workplace and had to improvise without being able to speak the same language. And it could be kind of nerve-wracking. Martha would train people on the saw line.
她说当拉丁裔工人出现时，他们和当地工人有点被扔在一起，在这个节奏很快的工业工作场所，必须在无法说同一种语言的情况下即兴交流。这可能让人很紧张。玛莎会在锯线岗位培训新人。
Doesn't that feel kind of dangerous to be training somebody on how to use a saw when you can't really--
在不能真正……的情况下培训别人使用锯子，难道不觉得有点危险吗？
Any time you trained somebody, yes, it was dangerous. That's the reason they only had certain people to train them, that had patience with them. I show him right here-- get the bird out. And I say-- [SLAPPING SOUND]
任何时候你培训别人，是的，这很危险。这就是为什么他们只让某些有耐心的人来培训他们。我展示给他看——把鸡拿出来。我说——[拍打声]
You'd pat it?
你会拍它吗？
Into the saw, into the saw.
进锯子里，进锯子里。
But while they were working side by side there was this feeling of like, where'd these people come from? Why were they here all of a sudden and so many of them?
但当他们并肩工作时，有一种感觉，就像，这些人是从哪里来的？为什么他们突然来到这里，而且有这么多人？
It's kind of like an uneasy feeling. You're unsure. You don't know whether to trust them or whether not to trust them. And we didn't know whether they were legal, or they weren't legal or what. But there was a lot of them. You know, there's not-- I mean, you can just tell by the way they act.
这有点像是一种不安的感觉。你不确定。你不知道该不该信任他们，或者不该信任他们。我们不知道他们是合法的，还是不合法的，或者是怎么回事。但他们人数很多。你知道，不是……我是说，你可以从他们的行为中看出来。
How's that?
怎么看？
They have a guard up on them.
他们有防备心理。
Like they don't want to get too close--
就像他们不想太亲近——
Like they don't want to get too close. They don't want to make conversation about certain things. And you have one that says I'm legal. I'm legal. I'm legal. And she gets fired three times because of bad paperwork.
就像他们不想太亲近。他们不想谈论某些事情。你有一个人说我是合法的。我是合法的。我是合法的。然后她因为文书错误被解雇了三次。
So I mean, how much would you ask? Was there a period where you were asking about it, and then you just--
所以，我是说，你问了多少？有一段时间你在询问这件事，然后你只是——
Some of them would would act like they don't know-- no comprende, you know? That is when they don't want to tell you nothing.
有些人会表现得好像他们不知道——听不懂，你知道吗？那是当他们不想告诉你任何事的时候。
There were a lot of things that just look really sketchy. People would get fired and come back to work. And when they came back, they had a different name. Pat remembers watching one woman fill out a form they had if you wanted to get your birthday off. The woman was young, maybe early 30s.
有很多事情看起来真的很可疑。人们会被解雇，然后又回来工作。当他们回来时，他们换了名字。帕特记得看着一个女人填写他们有的表格，如果你想请假过生日的话。那个女人很年轻，可能30出头。
And the birthday she put down had her 66 years old.
她填写的生日显示她有66岁了。
And we have girls over the years, they had their 15 coming out parties?
这些年来我们工厂也有女孩，她们举行了15岁成年礼（quinceaneras）吗？
That's Martha again, and she's talking about quinceaneras, which you celebrate when you turn 15.
那是玛莎，她在谈论15岁成年礼，这是当你满15岁时庆祝的节日。
They was giving out invitations.
她们在派发邀请函。
They were handing them out at work?
她们在工作时派发这些？
Well, they did, until one of them got in trouble and they fired her. But yeah, she was so proud of it. So she started giving out invitations. And then that's how they found out she was lying about her age.
嗯，她们确实这么做了，直到其中一个人惹了麻烦，他们解雇了她。但是的，她对此感到非常自豪。所以她开始派发邀请函。然后他们就是这样发现她在年龄上撒谎的。
How did you feel about that?
你对此有什么感觉？
Well, I didn't like it. I didn't like it-- the way they was sneaking in over here. And the company knows it.
嗯，我不喜欢。我不喜欢——他们偷偷溜进来的方式。而且公司知道这一点。
It seemed like the Mexicans were getting away with something. They were cheating the system. They were not here legally, and the company was helping them do it. Maybe the Mexicans weren't paying the same taxes. Lots of workers believe that, though, it wasn't true. The companies were required to take them out automatically.
看起来墨西哥人好像在蒙混过关。他们在欺骗系统。他们并非合法在这里，而公司在帮助他们这样做。也许墨西哥人没有缴纳同样的税款。很多工人都相信这一点，尽管事实并非如此。公司被要求自动扣除这些税款。
Regardless, longtime workers started to believe the same thing that Jeff Sessions came to believe, that these new immigrants were taking jobs that didn't belong to them. A quiet resentment set in among the white workers at the plants. Everyone says you'd walk in and you could feel it. We'll hear the company's side of all this in the second half of the show.
无论如何，长期工人开始相信杰夫·塞申斯所相信的事情，即这些新移民抢走了不属于他们的工作。在工厂的白人工人中，一种沉默的怨恨开始滋生。每个人都说当你走进去时，你能感觉到它。我们将在节目的下半部分听到公司的立场。
They have a totally different story to tell. But the icing on the cake for the workers was that the company seemed to like what was happening. In fact, maybe they were even behind it. There's this thing I heard over and over from almost every local I talked to. Again, here's Pat and Martha.
他们有一个完全不同的故事要讲。但对工人们来说，锦上添花的是，公司似乎喜欢正在发生的事情。事实上，也许他们甚至是幕后推手。我从我交谈过的几乎每个当地人那里一遍又一遍地听到这件事。再次，这是帕特和玛莎。
I don't know whether it was true or not, but we were told that there was a sign put up at the border-- work in Albertville, Alabama, poultry.
我不知道那是真的还是假的，但我们被告知在边境竖起了一个标志——在阿拉巴马州阿尔伯特维尔的家禽工厂工作。
It had a 800 number that you could call.
它有一个你可以拨打的800号码。
And it's on the border where?
那个标志在哪里？
Right as you go into Texas.
就在你进入德克萨斯州的时候。
So do you think that's true, or do you think that's fake?
所以你认为那是真的，还是你认为那是假的？
Yes, it was true.
是的，是真的。
Are you positive it was true?
你确定那是真的吗？
Yes. Yes.
是的。是的。
Where have you seen it? You saw a picture or what?
你在哪里看到的？你看到过照片还是什么？
I seen a picture of it.
我见过它的照片。
I never could find a picture of it. Some locals said it was more than one billboard. Some said it was in Texas. One woman said she saw it in Tijuana. But always, the sign named exactly one town in the whole country-- Albertville, Alabama.
我从来没能找到它的照片。一些当地人说不止一个广告牌。一些说在德克萨斯州。一个女人说她在蒂华纳看到了。但总是，那个标志在全国范围内只命名了一个城镇——阿拉巴马州的阿尔伯特维尔。
Did that make you feel betrayed by the company?
这让你觉得被公司背叛了吗？
Yes, it did. Yes, it did. Because I put years in here. And I have drawed chickens, hung chickens, dumped chickens, pushed dead chickens, sawed, shoveled eyes, stacked boxes, cleaned chicken poop off of coops, and everything else. That is my plant. Still to this day, that is my plant.
是的，觉得。是的，觉得。因为我在这里投入了多年时间。我拔过鸡毛、挂过鸡、倒过鸡、推过死鸡、锯过鸡、铲过眼、堆过箱子、清理过鸡笼里的鸡粪，以及其他所有工作。这是我的工厂。直到今天，那依然是我的工厂。
Who did you feel mad at? Did you feel mad at the Latinos? Were you mad at the company? Or was it--
你对谁感到生气？你对拉丁裔生气吗？你对公司生气吗？还是——
No, I wasn't mad at the Latinos. I was mad at management. They were scheming, conniving, taking shortcuts to get them in. I'm mad-- I'm not mad. I'm upset. I'm hurt, really.
不，我没对拉丁裔生气。我生管理层气。他们在搞阴谋、勾结，走捷径把他们弄进来。我生气——我不是生气。我是难过。我是受伤，真的。
So was there a sign at the border? I talked to a bunch of the men who came to Albertville in that first wave of Mexican workers about whether that's what brought them to town.
那么边境上有标志吗？我和第一波墨西哥工人中来到阿尔伯特维尔的一群人谈过，询问这是否是带他们来镇上的原因。
Have you heard that?
你听说过吗？
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
No, no, no. [SPEAKING SPANISH]
不，不，不。[西班牙语交谈]
I didn't know that.
我不知道。
Have you heard about this?
你听说过这个吗？
No. [SPEAKING SPANISH]
没有。[西班牙语交谈]
But I don't think it's true.
但我不认为这是真的。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语交谈]
Yeah, it's funny.
是的，很有趣。
Have you heard about this sign?
你听说过这个标志吗？
[SPEAKING SPANISH] [LAUGHTER]
[西班牙语交谈] [笑声]
No, I don't know anything about that.
不，我对那件事一无所知。
So you were laughing. What makes you laugh about that?
所以你在笑。什么让你笑？
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语交谈]
Because they're saying that Wayne Farms is putting these--
因为他们说Wayne Farms正在放置这些——
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语交谈]
--yeah, they're putting these signs up at the border, and why at the border?
——是的，他们把这些标志放在边境，为什么是在边境？
So that Mexicans can see them and come get a job.
这样墨西哥人就能看到它们，然后来找份工作。
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
They literally never heard of this. They worked side by side with the local workers for 20 years and had no idea that this was the story going around about them. This is a story that every local we talked to had heard of. So, no, they were not in the US because of a sign at the border.
他们真的从未听说过这件事。他们与当地工人并肩工作了20年，根本不知道关于他们的这些传闻。这是我们交谈过的每个当地人都听说过的故事。所以，不，他们在美国并不是因为边境上的标志。
In fact, what the American workers didn't know about these guys is that lots of these men who arrived in the early '90s had been in this country for years. They were not newly arrived immigrants stealing American jobs. They'd been here working and got amnesty when Ronald Reagan signed his big immigration reform in 1986. It legalized almost 3,000,000 people.
事实上，美国工人们对这些人所不知道的是，许多在90年代初到达的人已经在该国待了好几年了。他们不是偷走美国工作的刚到的移民。他们一直在这里工作，并在罗纳德·里根（Ronald Reagan）于1986年签署他的大型移民改革法案时获得了大赦。它使近300万人合法化。
Some were seasonal workers in the tomato fields close to Albertville. Some were on farms in Oregon, California, Florida, Michigan. Some did construction work. They made their way to town, and the chicken plant seemed like a good deal. This was work that would happen regardless of rain or snow, no off months, a reliable paycheck. And even better, they could finally stay in one place, which meant they could also finally bring their families from Mexico.
有些人是阿尔伯特维尔附近番茄地里的季节性工人。有些人曾在俄勒冈州、加利福尼亚州、佛罗里达州、密歇根州的农场工作。有些人做建筑工作。他们来到镇上，家禽加工厂看起来是一笔好买卖。这是一份无论下雨还是下雪都会进行的工作，没有淡季，有稳定的工资。更好的是，他们终于可以待在一个地方了，这意味着他们终于可以把家人也从墨西哥接过来。
This worker, we'll call Carlos, is pretty typical of that first wave. He'd been in the US since the '70s, got amnesty under Reagan, had five kids and a wife in Guanajuato that he only got to see once a year. He says he tried to stay connected to them by sometimes putting on his best clothes and going out with a camera.
这位工人，我们叫他卡洛斯（Carlos），是第一波移民的典型代表。他从70年代就在美国了，在里根政府下获得了大赦，在瓜纳华托（Guanajuato）有五个孩子和一个妻子，他一年只能见他们一次。他说他试图通过有时穿上最好的衣服带着相机出去走走来保持与他们的联系。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语交谈]
I would send them pictures, some pictures of, like, standing next to a car or a big house, and maybe they would think that I lived there.
我会寄给他们照片，一些比如站在汽车或大房子旁的照片，也许他们会以为我住在那里。
[SPEAKING SPANISH] [LAUGHTER]
[西班牙语交谈] [笑声]
But that wasn't your car or house?
但那不是你的车或房子？
No, no, no, no, no, no. [SPEAKING SPANISH]
不，不，不，不，不，不。[西班牙语交谈]
You start missing the love of your child, especially when you're gone for a year, and you miss them growing up.
你会开始想念孩子的爱，特别是当你离开了一年，你错过了他们的成长。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语交谈]
He was the foreman of an apple orchard in Michigan, a good job. But in Albertville, his wife could work with him at the chicken plant, double their income. They could send their kids to a much better school than back home.
他曾是密歇根州一个苹果园的领班，一份不错的工作。但在阿尔伯特维尔，他的妻子可以和他一起在鸡肉加工厂工作，收入翻倍。他们可以让孩子上比家乡好得多的学校。
And so after the first wave of men moved to town, word spread about these jobs, and the population started to shift from people who were in the country legally to lots of workers and family members who were not, who moved here directly from Mexico, arriving into town in packed cars and vans. Carlos says he brought his family legally but also told lots of people back home.
因此，在第一波男性移居到小镇后，这些工作岗位的消息传开了，人口开始从合法在美国的人转向大量并非合法在此的工人及其家庭成员，他们直接从墨西哥搬到这里，坐着塞满人的汽车和货车到达小镇。卡洛斯说他把家人合法接了过来，但也告诉了家乡的很多人。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语交谈]
So you start spreading the word. I'll tell, like, maybe two, three other Mexicans. I'll say, hey, you should come here, because there is lots and lots of work.
所以你开始传播这个消息。我会告诉，比如，两三个其他的墨西哥人。我会说，嘿，你应该来这里，因为这里有非常非常多的工作。
They needed the work, because Mexico was in economic crisis. The currency crashed in 1994. NAFTA knocked lots of Mexicans out of work and hit small farmers hard, and a surge of people came to the United States. The number of undocumented people here more than tripled from 3.5 million in 1990 to over 11 million in 2010.
他们需要这些工作，因为墨西哥处于经济危机中。货币在1994年崩溃。北美自由贸易协定（NAFTA）使许多墨西哥人失业，并严重打击了小农户，大批人来到了美国。这里非法移民的数量从1990年的350万增加到了2010年的超过1100万，增长了三倍多。
And large numbers were arriving in the southeast US for the first time. Carlos guessed that maybe 3,000 came to Albertville from his hometown at Guanajuato. Lots of people told us they liked how small Albertville was. That it wasn't a big city. It was pretty. It felt safe. It reminded them of home.
而且大量的人是第一次到达美国东南部。卡洛斯估计可能从他的家乡瓜纳华托有3000人来到了阿尔伯特维尔。许多人告诉我们，他们喜欢阿尔伯特维尔的小巧。它不是一个大城市。它很漂亮。感觉很安全。这让他们想起了家。
So when American workers in the Albertville plants looked around and wondered why in the world all these newcomers were suddenly showing up in their little town, this was the thing they didn't realize-- that an historic migration was under way, mostly from Mexico. The newcomers ended up in poultry plants all across the South-- Arkansas, Mississippi, Georgia, the Carolinas.
所以当阿尔伯特维尔工厂的美国工人环顾四周，纳闷为什么世界上所有这些新来者突然出现在他们的小镇上时，这是他们没意识到的一点——一场历史性的移民正在进行中，主要来自墨西哥。新来者最终遍布整个南部的家禽加工厂——阿肯色州、密西西比州、乔治亚州、卡罗来纳州。
Because coincidentally, the poultry business was going through its own massive changes. It was desperate for employees. The poultry business was booming in the early '90s like it never had before. The industry had figured out how to make chickens grow to full size more cheaply in a much shorter period of time. And they were rebranding chicken from the special meal that you'd have once a week to total ubiquity, a healthy, convenient alternative to red meat.
因为巧合的是，家禽业本身正在经历巨大的变化。它迫切需要员工。家禽业在90年代初蓬勃发展，前所未有。该行业已经研究出如何以更低的成本在更短的时间内让鸡长到全尺寸。他们正在将鸡肉从你每周吃一次的特殊餐点重新定位为完全普及的食品，一种健康、方便的红肉替代品。
[MUSIC - "CHICKEN TONIGHT"]
[音乐 - “CHICKEN TONIGHT”]
This Ragu commercial haunts the dreams of a generation of TV watchers. There's also the less healthy fast food version of chicken. Tyson started production of the McNugget for McDonald's, and soon chicken was everywhere.
这个Ragu广告困扰着一代电视观众的梦想。还有不那么健康的快餐版鸡肉。泰森（Tyson）开始为麦当劳生产麦乐鸡，很快鸡肉就随处可见了。
(SINGING) Well, they got chicken at Taco Bell. That's right, 'cause it's brand new.
[歌唱] 好吧，塔可钟（Taco Bell）有鸡肉了。没错，因为它是全新的。
That's Little Richard for Taco Bell. Homer Simpson advertised Church's Chicken.
那是小理查德（Little Richard）为塔可钟做的广告。荷马·辛普森（Homer Simpson）为Church's Chicken做过广告。
Ooh, chicken! Must eat! Need money, any means necessary!
喔，鸡肉！一定要吃！需要钱，不择手段！
The price dropped dramatically. People went from eating about 28 pounds of chicken a year in 1960 to almost 90 pounds per person per year today. Albertville's plants added the lines that took whole chickens and cut them up into the options you now see in the grocery store-- wings, tenders, boneless and skinless thighs and breasts. Their international market exploded, shipping dark meats, organs, and feet to Russia and China.
价格大幅下降。人们从1960年每年吃约28磅鸡肉增加到今天每人每年吃近90磅。阿尔伯特维尔的工厂增加了将整只鸡切割成你在杂货店看到的各种选择的生产线——翅膀、嫩肉、去骨去皮的大腿和鸡胸肉。他们的国际市场爆发式增长，向俄罗斯和中国出口深色肉、器官和鸡爪。
And that's the engine that was pulling in all these new workers to Albertville. The plant that's now Tyson Foods nearly quadrupled, from 250 workers to more than 900. Wayne Farms added around another 200 jobs. If there hadn't been a flood of new foreign workers to take those jobs, the companies might have had to pay more to attract employees to the plants. But that was not a choice they ever had to make.
这就是吸引所有这些新工人到阿尔伯特维尔的引擎。现在的泰森食品公司工厂几乎扩大了四倍，从250名工人增加到900多人。Wayne Farms又增加了大约200个工作岗位。如果没有涌入大量外国工人来担任这些工作，公司可能不得不支付更多的钱来吸引员工到工厂。但那不是他们必须做出的选择。
For the people who came with no papers, all the stuff that seemed so underhanded and devious to their American coworkers, it was surprisingly easy to pull off. This guy Oscar arrived in Albertville from Guanajuato in 1995, right before he turned 16, to join his father in the chicken plants. Legal age to work in a plant was 18, but that wasn't an obstacle.
对于那些没有证件的人来说，所有那些在他们的美国同事看来如此卑劣和诡计多端的事情，做起来却出奇地容易。这个叫奥斯卡（Oscar）的家伙在1995年刚满16岁之前从瓜纳华托来到阿尔伯特维尔，加入他父亲在鸡肉加工厂的工作。在工厂工作的法定年龄是18岁，但这并不是障碍。
He gave me a card, like ID.
他给了我一张卡片，像身份证一样。
Did he find you like a fake ID? Or what did you--
他找人给你弄了假身份证吗？还是你——
Yeah. He found me a fake ID with my-- I think it was not even my face.
是的。他给我找了一张假身份证，带上我的……我想那甚至都不是我的脸。
It wasn't even your face?
甚至不是你的脸？
No. The guy was older than me.
不。那个家伙比我大。
And did you think, this is not going to work?
你当时想，这行不通吧？
Yeah. Because, I mean, I was 16. And when I see the pictures, I was like, oh, my god.
是的。因为，我是说，我当时16岁。当我看到照片时，我心想，天哪。
The guy in the ID was probably 25, 26. His name was Jose Lopez. And from then on, that's the name that Oscar went by.
身份证上的那个家伙可能25、26岁。他的名字叫何塞·洛佩斯（Jose Lopez）。从那时起，这就是奥斯卡使用的名字。
They call me Joe.
他们叫我乔（Joe）。
Do you kind of think of yourself as Joe?
你把自己当成乔了吗？
Yeah. Imagine, working for 20 years-- I think it's 19, 20 years-- with that name. So it's like, I guess that's my nickname forever, I guess.
是的。想象一下，工作了20年——我想是19、20年——用那个名字。所以，我想那永远是我的昵称了。
Joe?
乔？
Yeah.
是的。
It's like a stage name, like an actor, but for the chicken plant.
就像一个艺名，像个演员，但为了鸡肉工厂。
Yeah.
是的。
How much did your American coworkers ask you about your legal status?
你的美国同事问过你的合法身份吗？
A bunch.
问过很多。
So how would they ask it? What would they say?
他们怎么问的？他们会说什么？
What's your real name?
你真名叫什么？
What would you say?
你会怎么说？
I would say, Jose. They said, no, that's not. I heard somebody call you another name. I tell him, that was my nickname.
我会说，何塞。他们说，不，不是。我听到有人叫你另一个名字。我告诉他，那是我的昵称。
Could you tell-- did that make them mad? Or what did they think about that?
你能说出来——那让他们生气了吗？或者他们是怎么想的？
They say that Mexicans go back to Mexico.
他们说墨西哥人滚回墨西哥去。
Is there any part of that you're like, oh, it's understandable?
有没有哪一部分你觉得，噢，是可以理解的？
Well, I don't really know. It's hard. When you don't have no more choice. I mean, you have to.
嗯，我真的不知道。很难。当你别无选择的时候。我的意思是，你必须这样做。
It was really striking talking to them-- how the arrival of these Latino workers blew the minds of the local workers, turned their world upside down. But the Mexican workers didn't have any of that. They didn't have a lot of emotions about their white coworkers, didn't spend a lot of time thinking or worrying about them.
与他们交谈真的令人震惊——这些拉丁裔工人的到来如何让当地工人感到震惊，颠覆了他们的世界。但墨西哥工人并没有那样的感受。他们对白人同事没有太多情绪，也没有花太多时间去思考或担心他们。
If the white workers didn't like them, whatever. They'd been through worse. Again, here's Fernando-- the guy who called Pat, Patricia.
如果白人工人不喜欢他们，随他们便吧。他们经历过更糟的。再次，这是费尔南多——那个叫帕特为帕特里夏的家伙。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语交谈]
You notice that people are staring at you, because you're something strange. And they're thinking, where do these people come from?
你注意到人们盯着你看，因为你是个陌生人。他们在想，这些人是从哪里来的？
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语交谈]
And they would just kind of glance at you to the side, like they don't want you there.
他们只是瞥你一眼，就像他们不想让你在那里一样。
How frustrating is that?
这有多令人沮丧？
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语交谈]
You don't really feel bad, because you get used to it.
你并不真的感到难过，因为你习惯了。
This guy named Claudio said he started trying to learn English, because he sensed his American coworkers were talking about him.
一个叫克劳迪奥（Claudio）的家伙说，他开始尝试学习英语，因为他感觉到他的美国同事在谈论他。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语交谈]
And I would think, well, what are they saying? And so I'd come back home, and I would ask my daughter. So what they were saying were swear words in English.
我会想，好吧，他们在说什么？所以我回到家，问我的女儿。他们说的是英语里的脏话。
He says his daughter was in elementary school. Quick warning, this story has a curse word we've unbeeped here on the podcast. Anyway, one day, one of his American coworkers got mad at the way he was hanging live birds on the conveyor belt.
他说他的女儿在读小学。小提醒，这个故事包含了一个我们在播客中没有消音的脏话。不管怎样，有一天，他的一位美国同事对他挂活鸡在传送带上的方式感到生气。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语交谈]
He was saying that I was skipping a hanger, and then he would say to me--
他说我漏掉了一个挂钩，然后他对我说——
Hey, you motherfucker, Mexican.
嘿，你这混蛋，墨西哥人。
Hey, motherfucker! Why are you skipping this? You know? Why do Mexicans come here if they're not going to work?
嘿，混蛋！你为什么要跳过这个？你知道吗？如果墨西哥人不打算工作，他们为什么要来这里？
So then you come home and you ask your daughter, what is motherfucker?
所以你回到家问你女儿，混蛋是什么意思？
Right. [SPEAKING SPANISH]
没错。[西班牙语交谈]
She would write down for me how it's spelled and then how it's said. And I would have it on a piece of paper that I would carry with me.
她会为我写下它是怎么拼写的，然后是怎么说的。我会在一张纸上写下来，随身携带。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语交谈]
She would say, hey, dad, just use the same word with them.
她会说，嘿，爸爸，就用同样的词对付他们。
Again, here's Fernando.
再次，这是费尔南多。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语交谈]
A lot of times, they talk about you, and they'd use that word that they have-- wetbackers-- to describe you.
很多时候，他们谈论你，会使用那个词——“湿背佬”（wetbackers）——来形容你。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语交谈]
One time, I got mad and hit somebody in the face with a chicken, like this. He didn't do anything. He just kind of walked off. And this was the guy who ran that line.
有一次，我生气了，像这样拿鸡打了某人的脸。他什么也没做。他只是走开了。那是管那条线的人。
You hit him with a chicken? Did that feel good to do that?
你用鸡打了他的脸？那样做感觉很好吗？
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语交谈]
Well, you don't exactly feel good, but you feel a little bit calmer because that gets the person to shut up.
嗯，你并不真的感觉很好，但你觉得平静了一点，因为那能让那个人闭嘴。
He says he could get away with talking back because he had papers. There's no official estimate of how much of Albertville's Latino population was undocumented back then or is undocumented now. But people who know the community best-- who work as advocates and deal with tons of families-- say it's more than half undocumented. And maybe a lot more than half. The first waves were from Mexico. And then later, people from Guatemala and elsewhere.
他说他敢反抗，因为他有证件。对于阿尔伯特维尔的拉丁裔人口中非法移民的比例，当时并没有官方估计，现在也没有。但最了解这个社区的人——那些担任拥护者并与大量家庭打交道的人——说超过一半是非法的。也许远不止一半。第一波人来自墨西哥。后来，来自危地马拉和其他地方的人也来了。
Lots of local workers said it wasn't long before management seemed to prefer the new Latino workers-- thought they were better workers. They picked up double shifts, didn't want to call attention to themselves or cause any problems. They didn't want to do anything that could make them lose their jobs-- didn't complain, didn't make a big deal about injuries. This is true even for the documented workers.
很多当地工人说，没过多久，管理层似乎就更喜欢新的拉丁裔工人了——认为他们是更好的工人。他们会接双班，不想引起注意或造成任何麻烦。他们不想做任何可能导致他们失去工作的事情——不抱怨，不对受伤大惊小怪。即使对于合法工人来说也是如此。
The government calls meat and poultry processing one of the most hazardous industries in the country. People get cut from working with sharp knives and scissors, they develop carpal tunnel syndrome from all the repetitive motion on the line. Carlos said that when he and his wife would get swollen hands from working on the line, he'd press on his fingers and blood and yellow puss would come out, chicken bones would get stuck under his fingernails, but he would just keep working.
政府将肉类和家禽加工称为该国最危险的行业之一。人们因为使用锋利的刀和剪刀而受伤，因为流水线上所有的重复动作而患上腕管综合症。卡洛斯说，当他和妻子因为在流水线上工作而手肿胀时，他会按压手指，血和黄色脓液就会出来，鸡骨头会卡在指甲下，但他只会继续工作。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语交谈]
I had to take out the guts with my two hands. And I really wanted to leave, but I said, no, I have to do this work, this hard work.
我必须用我的双手取出内脏。我真的很想离开，但我说，不，我必须做这项工作，这项艰苦的工作。
So when I talk to American workers, they say, I get mad when they say Mexicans work harder than white people. And they're like, it's not true. It's just that they don't speak up for their rights. And I was wondering what you think about that.
所以当我跟美国工人交谈时，他们说，当他们说墨西哥人比白人工作更努力时，我会生气。他们觉得那不是真的。只是他们不为自己的权利说话。我想知道你对此怎么看。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语交谈]
Yeah. We don't really know our rights. So we don't really know how to defend our rights in the work place. So, yeah, that's kind of a reason. But it's also because we have these families that are suffering that depend on us. I mean, they have us working from the time that we were kids, eight years old. Here, that doesn't really exist. So we do work harder.
是的。我们真的不知道我们的权利。所以我们并不真正知道如何在工作场所捍卫我们的权利。所以，是的，这是个原因。但这也是因为我们有这些受苦受难依赖我们的家庭。我是说，他们让我们从还是孩子的时候，八岁起就开始工作。在这里，这不存在。所以我们确实工作得更努力。
Carlos agrees with the local workers-- that the companies prefer Latinos. He'd see it play out at his plant.
卡洛斯同意当地工人的看法——公司更喜欢拉丁裔。他在他的工厂里亲眼所见。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语交谈]
With my boss, I'll be talking to him, and like five workers will come along, and two of them will be Hispanic. And my boss will say to me, hey, give me those two, because they're going to have better work ethic, whereas the other people might not last as long. They might leave. But the plant loses money when that happens. And so my boss will say, those two-- those two are going to last.
和我的老板交谈时，会有五个工人走过来，其中两个是西班牙裔。我的老板会对我打招呼说，嘿，给我那两个，因为他们会有更好的职业道德，而其他人可能坚持不了那么久。他们可能会离开。但工厂在发生这种情况时会损失钱财。所以我的老板会说，那两个——那两个会坚持下去的。
And we felt bad when the supervisors turned on us.
当我们被主管针对时，我们感到难过。
This worker asked that we don't use his name.
这位工人要求我们不要使用他的名字。
I think they felt that the Hispanics was more over-- above us. And I didn't see no difference. I mean, I thought, well, I can do just as much as this guy can, you know? But they didn't see that in us. They saw it in them. And after that, it seemed like it just changed-- like they turned on us and forgot about us. We felt forgotten.
我想他们觉得西班牙裔比我们……在上面。我看不到任何区别。我是说，我想，好吧，我能做得和这个家伙一样多，你知道吗？但他们没有在我们身上看到这一点。他们只在他们身上看到了。从那以后，似乎一切都变了——就像他们针对我们，忘了我们一样。我们感到被遗忘了。
We just felt like our jobs was in jeopardy. And from the time I clock in until the time I clock out, I was worried about what's going to happen to my future here at the chicken plant.
我们只是觉得我们的工作岌岌可危。从我打卡上班到打卡下班，我都在担心我在鸡肉加工厂的未来会怎样。
He was one of a handful of black workers at his plant. When Latino workers came in, he says it was the first time he felt unified with his white coworkers-- both saw themselves as the American workers. Again, here's Pat.
他是他工厂里少数几个黑人工人之一。当拉丁裔工人进来时，他说这是他第一次感到与白人同事团结一致——他们都把自己看作美国工人。再次，这是帕特。
It made us all think that we were just going to be pushed out the door, and they were going to bring all Hispanics in to replace us. Especially as older hands, you have a fear, all of a sudden, just slap you.
这让我们都以为我们会被推到门外，而他们会把所有西班牙裔人带进来取代我们。特别是作为老手，你会突然感到恐惧。
Coming up, the government steps in on the side of the local workers. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
接下来，政府站出来站在了当地工人这一边。那将在稍后，来自芝加哥公共广播电台，当我们的节目继续时。
This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, what actually happens when immigrants arrive in large numbers? We're telling the story of Albertville, Alabama, which went from being a nearly all-white, Southern town to a town that's now lots of immigrants-- more than half of them undocumented, best as we can tell. My co-host for the hour is Miki Meek.
《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天在我们的节目中，当移民大量到达时实际上发生了什么？我们正在讲述阿拉巴马州阿尔伯特维尔的故事，它从一个几乎全是白人的南方小镇变成了一个现在有很多移民的小镇——据我们所知，其中超过一半是非法的。这一小时的联合主持人是米基·米克。
And at this point in our story, the longtime workers in the chicken plants have this feeling that there's right, and there's wrong, and people are breaking the law-- obviously, here illegally. And everybody's acting like this is just fine, and normal, and what the hell? And the companies seem to be not just fine with this but probably encouraging it. And some plants, evidence came in 1995, of just how much the companies knew and how far they'd go to keep undocumented workers in the plants.
在我们故事的这一点上，鸡肉加工厂的长期工人有一种感觉，有对，有错，人们在违法——显然，在这里是非法的。每个人都表现得这很好、很正常，到底是怎么回事？公司似乎不仅对此没意见，而且可能还在鼓励它。一些工厂在1995年出现了证据，表明公司知道多少，以及他们会走多远来保留非法工人在工厂里。
That year, the government decided to take aggressive action against the wave of undocumented Mexican workers that were moving into poultry plants, carpet factories, and hotel jobs all across the South. They launched a series of raids, called Operation SouthPAW. PAW was short for Protecting American Workers.
那一年，政府决定对进入南方各地家禽加工厂、地毯工厂和酒店工作的非法墨西哥工人浪潮采取激进行动。他们发起了一系列突袭，称为“南爪行动”（Operation SouthPAW）。PAW是“保护美国工人”（Protecting American Workers）的缩写。
In Washington today, the Immigration Service has announced a very bold move to locate and deport illegal aliens. Federal agents have actually gone into factories and farm fields to locate illegal immigrants. And then they've gone one step further--
今天在华盛顿，移民局宣布了一项非常大胆的举措，旨在定位和驱逐非法移民。联邦特工实际上已经进入了工厂和农田来定位非法移民。然后他们又更进一步——
The goal was to create job openings for American workers by arresting lots of people at work sites. A big show of force with over 100 INS and Border Patrol agents. They rode into Albertville with empty buses to haul people off to deportation. At the Gold Kist plant outside of town, workers cheered when they arrived. But at Hudson Foods, management had worked out a system to deal with the raids.
目标是通过在工作场所逮捕大量人员来创造美国工人的职位空缺。一场动用了超过100名移民局和边境巡逻特工的大规模展示武力行动。他们开着空巴士进入阿尔伯特维尔，要把人们带走遣返。在镇外的Gold Kist工厂，当他们到达时，工人们欢呼雀跃。但在Hudson Foods，管理层已经制定了一个系统来应对突袭。
I talked to Mark Ginzo. He worked at Hudson Foods as a bilingual chaplain. This is something you see at some chicken plants around the south-- chaplains to minister to the workers. Mark remembers they were raided a few times. And they'd know in advance if immigration was coming, because agents had to get a warrant first.
我跟马克·金佐（Mark Ginzo）谈过。他在Hudson Foods担任双语牧师。这是你在南方的一些鸡肉加工厂看到的现象——派牧师来照顾工人的精神生活。马克记得他们被突袭了几次。他们会提前知道移民局是否要来，因为特工必须先获得搜查令。
Usually it was somebody outside who would-- or they would look through the windows and see them coming in and start screaming, la migra! La migra!
通常是外面的某个人会——或者他们会透过窗户看到他们过来，然后开始尖叫，移民局（La migra）！移民局（La migra）！
And la migra means?
La migra是什么意思？
Immigration.
移民局。
Then what happens in the plant? What do you see happen?
然后工厂里发生了什么？你看到发生了什么？
Oh, you see people running all over the place-- you know, the Mexicans, of course. But they knew-- they knew where to go. They knew all the hiding places in the place.
噢，你看到人们到处乱跑——你知道，当然是墨西哥人。但他们知道——他们知道去哪里。他们知道工厂里的所有藏身处。
And where were those places in the plant?
那些地方在工厂里的哪里？
There was one particular room-- oh, my god. I felt so bad, because it was very cold. It was like freezing in there.
有一个特别的房间——噢，天哪。我感觉太糟糕了，因为它非常冷。那里冻死人了。
Was it the freezer?
是冷冻库吗？
Yeah. And they would put 15 or 20 of them in there and lock the door.
是的。他们会把15或20个人关在里面并锁上门。
And what is it that you're laughing about? What's making you laugh?
你笑什么？什么让你笑？
Well, it was funny because management was the one that cooperated to hide them.
嗯，这很有趣，因为管理层是合作隐藏他们的人。
Management would help hide them?
管理层会帮忙隐藏他们？
Yeah.
是的。
How? They would show people?
怎么做？他们会指引人？
Yeah. They would show people where the room-- and some would even hide in some of the management offices. Under the desks and closets-- anywhere we could hide them.
是的。他们会告诉人们房间在哪里——有些甚至会把人藏在一些管理办公室里。在桌子下和壁橱里——任何我们可以藏人的地方。
Wow.
哇。
I usually had four or five inside my office.
我的办公室里通常藏着四五个人。
This company, Hudson Foods, doesn't exist anymore. It was bought out. So we couldn't ask them to comment. But the INS agent who led the raid in Albertville, Bart Szafnicki, told me it was common for companies and all sorts of industries to hide workers. Sometimes it got ridiculous. He remembers a manager insisting he didn't have any undocumented workers, and then a guy fell through the ceiling and landed on his desk.
这家公司，Hudson Foods，已经不存在了。它被收购了。所以我们无法要求他们置评。但在阿尔伯特维尔领导突袭的移民局特工巴特·斯扎夫尼基（Bart Szafnicki）告诉我，各行各业的公司隐藏工人的情况很普遍。有时这变得很荒谬。他记得一位经理坚持说他没有任何非法工人，然后一个人从天花板上掉了下来，落在了他的办公桌上。
Bart pointed out, there's never been a serious crack down on employers. These raids were short lived. The fines were low. The chances of getting caught were small. Bart found it frustrating. Congress never had the political will to go after the companies that hire undocumented workers. There are congressmen who talk tough on immigration, but when INS went after work sites in their districts, they told them to back off.
巴特指出，从来没有真正严厉打击过雇主。这些突袭持续时间很短。罚款很低。被抓到的几率很小。巴特感到沮丧。国会从来没有政治意愿去追究那些雇佣非法工人的公司。有些国会议员在移民问题上大谈强硬立场，但当移民局在其选区追查工作场所时，他们让他们撤回。
Politically, it's always been easier to scapegoat the people who crossed the border than to go after employers. Martha and Pat's plant never got raided for whatever reason. But Martha told me some of their American coworkers took things into their own hands.
在政治上， scapegoat（寻找替罪羊）那些越境者总是比追究雇主更容易。玛莎和帕特的工厂出于某种原因从未被突袭。但玛莎告诉我，他们的一些美国同事采取了自行其是的行动。
I was on second shift. And we was sitting there one night. And they said, immigration is here. And that break room cleared out in this, shoom.
我在第二个轮班。有一天晚上我们坐在那里。他们说，移民局来了。那个休息室立刻就空了，咻。
So was immigration there or not really there?
所以移民局是在还是没在？
No, they wasn't there.
不，他们没在。
So were they just messing with them to be mean?
所以他们只是为了卑鄙而以此捉弄他们吗？
Yeah. It was just rumors. And you know who I'm talking about-- Wayne Gabel.
是的。那只是谣言。而且你知道我在说谁——韦恩·盖布尔（Wayne Gabel）。
Wayne Gable-- a maintenance worker now retired. He wasn't shy talking about this.
韦恩·盖布尔——一个已经退休的维修工人。他谈到这一点时毫不羞怯。
Somebody started the rumor out in the plant.
有人在工厂里散布了谣言。
Now, was that you?
那是你吗？
Most likely.
很有可能。
It was you.
是你。
Yeah. It was me.
是的。是我。
Why did you do that?
你为什么要这样做？
To see what would happen.
看看会发生什么。
It's kind of mean, right?
这有点刻薄，对吧？
No, it was funny. The Hispanic people move fast when they have to, especially when they think immigration's coming.
不，这很有趣。西班牙裔人在不得不动的时候移动得很快，特别是当他们认为移民局要来的时候。
They was running on top of the building. They was running out the gate at the back of the plant. And by the time they finally got everybody settled down and told them it wasn't happening and all that, we done lost 20.
他们跑到了大楼顶上。他们从工厂后门的栅栏跑了出去。等到他们终于让每个人都平静下来并告诉他们没有这回事时，我们已经少了20个。
People?
人？
That run, yeah. Because they was scared they was going to caught.
跑掉了，是的。因为他们害怕他们会被抓住。
Did they come back?
他们回来了吗？
No, no, no. They didn't come back, because they was afraid that--
不，不，不。他们没有回来，因为他们害怕——
So they didn't come back the next day?
所以他们第二天没回来？
No.
没有。
Like 20 people were gone-- just gone?
就像20个人都不见了——就那样不见了？
Right. And it's all because somebody told a lie. But we did get the three or four that was hiding on top of the roof. They did come back down. They let them go back on the line.
没错。这一切都因为有人说了谎。但我们确实抓到了躲在屋顶上的那三四个。他们确实下来了。他们让他们回到了流水线上。
Did you feel bad about it at all later?
你后来感到难过吗？
No. Because the company kept saying they was there legally, and I knew better. I knew the company was lying. So I wanted to find out.
没有。因为公司一直在说他们是合法在那里的，但我知道不是。我知道公司在撒谎。所以我想查清楚。
And did you get in trouble?
你有麻烦吗？
Well, they carried me to the office, and we had a little conversation. They threatened me, told me not do that no more, that they would fire me. And I told them-- I says, yeah? And I'll have immigration in here, and I'll have a lawsuit on you when you do-- for me telling the truth. Because y'all are lying anyway. And that proved my point. And that proved the point to everybody in that plant. They was all there illegally.
嗯，他们把我叫到办公室，我们进行了一次小谈话。他们威胁我，告诉我不要再那样做了，说他们会解雇我。我告诉他们——我说，是吗？那我会叫移民局来这里，当你这样做时，我会起诉你们——因为我说的是实话。因为无论如何你们都在撒谎。这证明了我的观点。这也向工厂里的每个人证明了这一点。他们所有人都是非法在那里的。
HR people who worked around Albertville at Tyson Foods, Wayne Farms, and Gold Kist, back in the mid '90s, told us that, sure, they suspected people were working under false papers. But they say, what could they do? Once an applicant presented documents proving they could work, the law limited them from probing and digging beyond that. Bruce Williams worked in HR at Wayne Farms back in the '90s.
90年代中期在阿尔伯特维尔周围的泰森食品、Wayne Farms和Gold Kist工作的人力资源人员告诉我们，当然，他们怀疑人们是在虚假证件下工作的。但他们说，他们能做什么？一旦申请人出示了证明他们可以工作的证件，法律就限制他们深入挖掘。布鲁斯·威廉姆斯（Bruce Williams）在90年代在Wayne Farms的人力资源部工作。
And the law will tell you, you can go no further. You can't just set him in the chair and put the bright light on them-- you know, where did you get these papers? Where were you born? What color house was it? You can't do that stuff unless you do it to every single individual you hire.
好的。法律会告诉你，你不能再深入了。你不能只是让他们坐在椅子上，用强光对着他们——你知道，这些证件你是从哪里弄来的？你在哪里出生的？房子的颜色是什么？除非你对你雇佣的每一个个人都这样做，否则你不能做那些事。
This is true. It goes back to President Reagan's 1986 Amnesty Law. That's the first time it became a crime in this country to knowingly hire somebody who should not be here. The key word in the law is knowingly. If a company knowingly hired somebody they shouldn't, that's when they got in trouble. But the law also said that if somebody's documents look legitimate, if they, quote, "appear to be genuine on their face, the employer must accept them and cannot question them or ask for more documentation." These are the rules that we still live under today.
这是真的。这要追溯到里根总统1986年的大赦法。这是在这个国家故意雇佣不该在此的人成为犯罪的第一时间。法律中的关键词是“故意”。如果一家公司故意雇佣了他们不该雇佣的人，那他们就会遇到麻烦。但法律还说，如果某人的证件看起来合法，如果它们“在表面上看起来是真实的”，雇主必须接受它们，不能质疑或要求更多证明。这些就是我们今天仍然生活在其中的规则。
And when the law was first passed, HR departments and companies all over the country were unprepared. They had no idea how to evaluate all the different forms of ID people were presenting-- birth certificates, and school records, and Native American tribal documents, and foreign passports with special work authorization stamps. They couldn't tell whether they seemed genuine on their face.
当法律首次通过时，全国各地的人力资源部门和公司都毫无准备。他们不知道如何评估人们提供的各种形式的身份证件——出生证明、学校记录、美洲原住民部落文件和带有特殊工作许可印章的外国护照。他们无法判断它们在表面上是否看起来是真的。
So in 1995, Congress, in a very practical, bipartisan way that we almost never see any more, decided that it had to fix the problem and come up with a simple way for employers to tell who is legal to work in the United States and who isn't, to figure out who they could hire.
所以在1995年，国会以一种我们在今天几乎再也看不到的非常务实、两党合作的方式，决定必须解决这个问题，想出一个简单的方法让雇主分辨谁是合法在美国工作的，谁不是，找出他们可以雇佣谁。
There is simply no time to lose.
真的没有时间可以浪费了。
Senator Dianne Feinstein warned, at the time, they had to solve this crisis now-- of immigrants coming in illegally and getting these jobs.
参议员黛安·范斯坦（Dianne Feinstein）当时警告说，他们现在必须解决这场移民非法涌入并获得这些工作的危机。
I fear an even more serious backlash nationwide against all immigrants, including those who want to come to our country legally.
我担心全国范围内对所有移民产生更严重的强烈抵制，包括那些想要合法来到我们国家的人。
Obviously, they didn't solve it. And here we are today. A bipartisan commission called the Jordan Commission considered a bunch of solutions. One of the things they ended up proposing was a national computerized system to check people's IDs, and make sure they were valid, and their social security numbers are real. This is the system we've come to know as E-Verify.
显然，他们没有解决它。我们今天就在这里。一个名为“乔丹委员会”（Jordan Commission）的两党委员会考虑了一堆解决方案。他们最终提议的一件事是一个全国性的计算机化系统来检查人们的身份证，确保它们有效，并且他们的社会保障号码是真实的。这就是我们所知道的电子验证系统（E-Verify）。
The commission wanted it to be mandatory everywhere, but an almost laughably wide ranging coalition rose up against it. This was the ACLU, plus the NRA, plus church groups, plus business interests, plus La Raza. They all saw it as Big Brother government intrusion. So a voluntary program moved forward. A few of the poultry plants in Albertville voluntarily signed up for the pilot program of E-Verify in the late '90s. Tom Howell, at Wayne Farms, says they were the first.
委员会希望它在各地强制执行，但一个笑话般广泛的联盟起来反对它。这是美国公民自由联盟（ACLU），加上全国步枪协会（NRA），加上教会团体，加上商业利益，加上拉拉扎（La Raza）。他们都将其视为“老大哥”式的政府入侵。所以一个自愿计划得以推进。阿尔伯特维尔的几家家禽加工厂在90年代末自愿签约参加了E-Verify的试点项目。Wayne Farms的汤姆·豪威尔说他们是第一批。
Because frankly, I wanted to make sure I knew what I was doing. And I had no way of knowing if somebody handed me a document, especially an alien card, whether or not it was legitimate or not. So I'll be honest with you, I didn't have a clue what I was looking for. And I was looking for any tool I could find.
因为坦率地说，我想确保我知道我在做什么。当有人递给我一份文件，特别是外籍人卡时，我没有办法知道它是否合法。所以我会对你说实话，我根本不知道我在找什么。我在寻找我能找到的任何工具。
So how much better was E-Verify then? What's the difference that E-Verify made?
所以那时的E-Verify好到什么程度？E-Verify带来的区别是什么？
To me, the big fallacy of it-- it would tell you that a document was valid, but it wouldn't tell you that the bearer of that document was actually the person that the document was for, if that makes any sense.
对我来说，它最大的谬误是——它会告诉你一份文件是有效的，但如果你明白我的意思，它不会告诉你文件的持有人实际上是不是文件所指的那个人。
What you're talking about is people using somebody else's papers.
你谈论的是人们使用别人的证件。
That's right. I mean, that was the fallacy of it, but it was the only thing available at the time. And we used it religiously.
没错。我的意思是，那是它的谬误，但那是当时唯一可用的东西。我们虔诚地使用了它。
I mean, I have talked to workers who did used to work here who were up front about the fact. They were like, yeah. I came here, and I used a fake ID, and I worked here.
我是说，我采访过以前在那里工作过的人，他们对那个事实是坦诚的。他们说，是的。我来了，我用了假身份证，我在那里工作。
Now, I'm not going to sit here and tell you that hasn't happened. But I can tell you that if we ever caught them, they weren't working here.
现在，我不会坐在这里告诉你那没发生过。但我可以告诉你，如果我们曾经抓到他们，他们就不会在那里工作了。
Workers confirmed this. Inviting your boss to your quinceanera was not a good idea. But like Tom said, E-Verify couldn't detect when someone presented valid papers that actually had been issued to someone else. And so lots of people slipped through.
工人们证实了这一点。邀请你的老板参加你的15岁成年礼不是一个好主意。但正如汤姆所说，E-Verify无法检测出某人出示的是其实际上已发给别人的有效证件。因此许多人溜了进来。
A study commissioned by the government in 2009 found that over half of undocumented workers with fake papers-- people E-Verify should have caught-- got a clean bill of health. What this means is that E-Verify worked out in a very convenient way for employers. They could simultaneously keep a huge illegal workforce while saying they were doing everything possible to root out that workforce. Pat says if she learned about someone who had a fake ID, sometimes she went to her supervisor and was told--
政府在2009年委托的一项研究发现，超过一半持假证件的非法工人——E-Verify本应抓到的人——得到了清白的证明。这意味着E-Verify对雇主来说以一种非常方便的方式运作。他们可以同时保留庞大的非法劳动力，同时声称他们正在尽一切努力铲除那些劳动力。帕特说如果她得知有人有假身份证，有时她会去找主管，然后被告知——
Everything on their paperwork checks out OK. What can we do? Her ID showed up good. Her ID showed up good.
他们的文书工作检查一切正常。我们能做什么？她的身份证显示是好的。她的身份证显示是好的。
So by the early 2000s, you have all these undocumented workers not getting caught by E-Verify working in the Albertville plants, which raises the central question you come to when we talk about immigration-- did Americans end up out of work because of it? As Jeff Sessions puts it--
所以到了21世纪初，你们有所有这些没有被E-Verify抓到的非法工人在阿尔伯特维尔的工厂工作，这提出了我们谈论移民时遇到的核心问题——美国人最终因为这个失业了吗？正如杰夫·塞申斯所说——
You let a bunch of people come in from out of the country to take what few jobs there are, leaving Americans unemployed.
你让一堆人从国外进来抢走本就不多的工作，让美国人失业。
Or as Martha says-- and by the way, she's a Democrat. Voted for Clinton.
或者正如玛莎所说——顺便说一句，她是民主党人。投给了克林顿。
You know, you need to hire Americans. You know, there are people out there that wants jobs. But there for many years, they just quit hiring Americans.
你知道，你需要雇佣美国人。你知道，外面有想要工作的人。但多年来，他们只是停止雇佣美国人。
So did these immigrants result in Americans out of work? To answer that, we turn to a labor economist who's made this kind of question his life's work, Giovanni Peri of the University of California, Davis.
那么这些移民导致美国人失业了吗？为了回答这个问题，我们转向了一位劳动经济学家，他把这类问题作为他毕生的事业，加州大学戴维斯分校的乔瓦尼·佩里（Giovanni Peri）。
Hi, Ira. Hi, Miki. Nice to talk to you today.
你好，艾拉。你好，米基。很高兴今天和你们交谈。
Peri did a study for us comparing the area around Albertville and counties in Alabama that had similar job markets but did not get a lot of immigrants. And it looked at the Americans most likely to lose their jobs to those immigrants, the ones competing against them for those poultry jobs. These are people who did not finish high school.
佩里为我们做了一项研究，比较了阿尔伯特维尔周边地区和阿拉巴马州那些有类似就业市场但没有接收大量移民的县。它观察了最有可能因那些移民而失业的美国人，那些与他们竞争家禽加工工作的工人。这些人是没有完成高中学业的人。
Were more of them out of a job? Was their unemployment rate higher around Albertville?
他们中更多人失业了吗？在阿尔伯特维尔周围他们的失业率更高吗？
No. So we don't find here a significant difference in the unemployment rate between Albertville and the comparison counties.
没有。所以我们在这里没有发现阿尔伯特维尔和对比县之间的失业率存在显著差异。
So even though a flood of immigrants came in, native-born workers were still finding jobs in equal numbers.
所以尽管涌入了大量移民，本地出生的工人在同样数量上仍然能找到工作。
Yes. Because the economy was becoming bigger. And these immigrants coming in in part were consumers. And so they created demand, also, for other jobs.
是的。因为经济变得更大了。而且这些涌入的移民部分是消费者。所以他们也创造了对其他工作的需求。
In other words, so many people moved to Albertville-- remember, it's over 6,000 people who moved in. And they had to rent places to live and buy groceries and gas and other stuff in this little town. And the labor fueled the expansion of the poultry plants and all the businesses associated with poultry.
换句话说，很多人搬到了阿尔伯特维尔——记住，那是超过6000人搬了进来。他们必须在这个小镇租房住、买杂货、汽油和其他东西。而劳动力推动了家禽工厂和与家禽相关的所有企业的扩张。
So even if fewer American workers were in the plants themselves, it created tons of work around town. And the numbers show the Americans found work elsewhere.
所以即使工厂本身的美国工人少了，它在镇上创造了大量工作。数据表明美国人在其他地方找到了工作。
What's interesting is that all of that was invisible to the local workers in the plants. They didn't see the economy of the whole town. They didn't see the jobs being created everywhere. They saw what was right in front of them in the plant, which was immigrants getting hired there.
有趣的是，工厂里的当地工人看不见这一切。他们看不见整个城镇的经济。他们看不见到处都在创造的工作岗位。他们只看见工厂里就在他们面前的事情，那就是移民被雇佣在那里。
They weren't wrong about that. By the early 2000s, just 10 years after Latino workers first arrived in the plants, they dominated the workforce there. Whites were in the minority. Again, here's Martha.
他们在那点上没错。到21世纪初，在拉丁裔工人首次到达工厂仅10年后，他们就在那里主导了劳动力。白人成了少数。再次，这是玛莎。
Well, you know, you go out there, and you get on the line. And you're the only white person. And you got 25 Hispanics. And right across from you on that line is all Hispanics. You're standing right there by yourself.
嗯，你知道，你走出去，上了流水线。你是唯一的白人。你有25个西班牙裔人。而在那条线上正对面全是西班牙裔。你一个人站在那里。
What was it like to suddenly be the minority in the plant?
突然成为工厂里的少数群体是什么感觉？
Well, it wasn't that bad when they started. But after they'd been there a while, they kind of thought they owned it. And there was more of them. You know, they kind of stay with their group, the family, you know, like aunts and cousins. And just about all of them's kin somehow, you know? They started changing their attitude.
嗯，他们刚开始的时候没那么糟。但他们待了一段时间后，他们有点认为他们拥有它了。而且他们的人更多。你知道，他们有点和他们的群体待在一起，家人，你知道，像阿姨和堂兄弟。而且他们几乎所有人都是亲戚，你知道吗？他们开始改变他们的态度。
What would come up?
会发生什么？
It was hard to work with them. Because they were speaking their language and talk about people and make fun of them. And Americans know they was talking or laughing at them.
和他们一起工作很难。因为他们说他们的语言，谈论别人并取笑他们。而美国人知道他们在谈论或嘲笑他们。
You know, and it started causing problems. We had quite a few fights in the breakrooms. Then we had them carried out to the parking lot, you know.
你知道，这开始引发问题。我们在休息室里打了几次架。然后我们把他们带到停车场解决，你知道。
Martha believes it's no accident that the workforce flipped like this. She believes the companies had a strong incentive to hire Latino workers rather than the locals. And the incentive was a big one. They didn't join the union, most of them anyway.
玛莎相信这种劳动力翻转并非偶然。她相信公司有强烈的动机雇佣拉丁裔工人而不是当地人。而动机非常巨大。他们没有加入工会，或者至少他们中的大多数没有。
The two big Albertville plants, Tyson Foods and Wayne Farms, are union shops. Which is unusual for poultry and unusual in Alabama, which is a right-to-work state. Which means workers can opt out of the union and not pay dues.
两个大型阿尔伯特维尔工厂，泰森食品和Wayne Farms，是工会车间。这在家禽业和阿拉巴马州是不寻常的，阿拉巴马州是一个“工作权”（right-to-work）州。这意味着工人可以选择退出工会，不缴纳会费。
Pat's a lifelong union member. Martha's chief steward at her plant. For years, the union had fought for better conditions and higher pay. And Pat and Martha's biggest frustration with her Latino coworkers is that they couldn't convince them to join.
帕特是终身的工会成员。玛莎是她工厂的首席干事。多年来，工会一直在争取更好的条件和更高的工资。而帕特和玛莎对她们的拉丁裔同事最大的挫败感是她们无法说服他们加入。
They don't understand it. All they see is that $9.10 coming out of their check every week for union dues. And they don't want to pay it.
他们不明白。他们所能看到的只是他们每周从工资支票中扣除的9.10美元工会会费。他们不想付钱。
Because they don't want to spend that money. They've got to send it home.
因为他们不想花那笔钱。他们必须把它寄回家。
The union could do awesome in a poultry plant if the Hispanics would unite and help us. I mean, we could rule the roost, you might say.
如果西班牙裔能团结起来帮助我们，工会在鸡肉加工厂可以做得非常好。我是说，你可能会说，我们可以统治鸡窝。
Latino workers we talked to confirmed this. They didn't want to pay the extra money. They get the same salary and benefits regardless of whether they paid dues and joined the union. So why bother? The union president during the '90s, Joe Ellis, agrees with Martha that the companies were deliberately hiring Latino workers as a strategy to weaken the union.
我们交谈过的拉丁裔工人证实了这一点。他们不想支付额外的钱。无论他们是否支付会费和加入工会，他们都得到相同的工资和福利。那为什么要费心呢？90年代的工会主席乔·埃利斯（Joe Ellis）同意玛莎的观点，即公司故意雇佣拉丁裔工人作为削弱工会的策略。
Oh, there is no doubt-- I mean, I could tell you that there is no doubt. There's no doubt. I mean, the results show that. I mean, there is no doubt about it. I mean, we had membership at those plants at that time, probably, 80% to 90%, or even 95%.
噢，毫无疑问——我是说，我可以告诉你毫无疑问。毫无疑问。我是说，结果表明了这一点。我是说，这毫无疑问。我是说，那时我们在那些工厂的成员人数，大概，有80%到90%，甚至95%。
Mm-hmm.
嗯。
And then when the Latinos come in, that changed. And when that changed, then the bargaining unit changed. Because we didn't have any bargaining power. So you were at their mercy.
然后当拉丁裔进来时，情况变了。当情况变了，谈判单位就变了。因为我们没有任何谈判能力。所以你任由他们摆布。
The union sent us records for 1991 that show membership at one of the plants, Wayne Farms, at 94.5%. Wayne Farms disputes this number, says membership has never been that high.
工会给我们发送了1991年的记录，显示其中一家工厂Wayne Farms的成员比例为94.5%。Wayne Farms对此数字提出异议，称成员比例从未达到那么高。
Today, the union says they're in the mid-40s at both union plants in town. The unions lost their 30-minute paid breaks. Raises are minimal.
今天，工会称他们在镇上的两个工会工厂的比例在40%多一点。工会失去了30分钟的带薪休息时间。加薪是微乎其微的。
The companies-- Wayne Farms and Tyson Foods-- were adamant that they were not hiring Latino workers as a strategy to weaken the union. They said they didn't do anything to specially recruit Latino workers. And by the way, as long as we're on the subject, they said they did not put up a sign or signs on the border with Mexico.
公司——Wayne Farms和泰森食品——坚决表示他们雇佣拉丁裔工人并非削弱工会的策略。他们说他们没有做任何特殊招募拉丁裔工人的事情。顺便说一句，既然我们谈到这个话题，他们说他们没有在与墨西哥的边境竖立标志。
They said what happened was simple. The population of people applying for jobs changed. And they hired whoever applied and was qualified.
他们说发生的事情很简单。申请工作的人口变了。他们雇佣了任何申请且合格的人。
Remember, these are plants with incredibly high turnover, always scrambling to hire people. And during the '90s, they got all their workers through the state employment office. It was the state employment office sending over the people to fill the jobs. And Latino applicants are who they sent. Bruce Williams was in HR during the '90s and 2000s at Wayne Farms.
记住，这些工厂的人员流动率高得惊人，总是争先恐后地雇佣人。在90年代，他们所有的工人都是通过州就业办公室获得的。是州就业办公室派人来填补这些空缺。而送来的正是拉丁裔申请人。布鲁斯·威廉姆斯在90年代和2000年代在Wayne Farms负责HR。
OK. If your application flow-- the number of applications you get in-- say it's 60%, 70% Hispanic, over a period of time. What does that tell you your workforce is going look like? It's just-- it's just plain arithmetic. You know, 'cause I remember telling a couple of people, all right. I needed 10 people. I got 50 applications this week. They were all Hispanic.
好的。如果你的申请流——你收到的申请数量——说有60%、70%是西班牙裔，经过一段时间。那告诉你的劳动力会是什么样子？这只是——这只是简单的算术。你知道，因为我记得告诉几个人，好的。我需要10个人。我这周收到了50份申请。它们全是西班牙裔。
Now who am I supposed to hire? Well, go out and find some white people. Well, why do you go find people? You've got people coming to you.
现在我该雇佣谁？好吧，出去找一些白人吧。好吧，你为什么要出去找人？你有人主动上门。
Even if the Albertville plants never actively sought out or recruited Latino workers, it's important to note that it's been documented that poultry companies elsewhere did by sending scouts to Texas and Florida and running ads in Spanish-language newspapers and radio stations. Tyson Foods was indicted in 2001 by federal prosecutors for recruiting workers from outside the United States, from Mexico and Central America, and helping them get fake documents. The government lost that case when it failed to prove that this was a company-sanctioned practice, not just some rogue employees at a few of the plants.
即使阿尔伯特维尔的工厂从未主动寻找或招募拉丁裔工人，重要的是要注意，已经有记录表明其他地方的家禽公司通过派遣侦察员到德克萨斯和佛罗里达，并在西班牙语报纸和广播电台投放广告来招募工人。泰森食品在2001年被联邦检察官起诉，指控其从美国境外，从墨西哥和中美洲招募工人，并帮助他们获得伪造证件。政府在那起案件中败诉，因为它未能证明这是一项公司认可的做法，而不仅仅是几家工厂里的一些流氓员工所为。
To be clear, the fact that so few local workers are in the plants today, Pat and Martha don't entirely blame the companies for that. Today, Pat no longer believes there was a sign on the border. They say it was a mixture of things.
明确地说，当地工人今天在工厂里如此之少的事实，帕特和玛莎并不完全责怪公司。今天，帕特不再相信边境上有标志。他们说这是一些因素的混合。
Their peers started to retire out. And their kids don't work at the plant. More kids in town are graduating high school and have other options for work. And they said some locals just didn't want to come to work at a place that's mostly Latino.
他们的同龄人开始退休了。他们的孩子不在工厂工作。镇上更多的孩子高中毕业，有其他的工作选择。而且他们说一些当地人只是不想去一个大部分是拉丁裔的地方工作。
But at the same time, they're convinced that there were periods where the companies did preferentially hire Latino workers, stretches where it really felt like locals couldn't get a job. They'd hear about locals putting in applications but taking a long time to get hired or not getting hired at all. And meanwhile, lots of Latino workers were coming through.
但同时，他们坚信在某些时期公司确实优先雇佣了拉丁裔工人，在那段时间里，感觉当地人确实无法找到工作。他们会听说当地人提交了申请，但雇佣得很慢，或者根本没有被雇佣。而与此同时，大量拉丁裔工人通过了。
And fact is it really was harder for local workers to get a job than it had been in the past. Pat and Martha and other locals were right about that. Latino workers would line up at 2:00 in the morning for job applications. And by the time local workers showed up, the jobs would be taken.
事实是，当地工人确实比过去更难找到工作。帕特和玛莎以及其他当地人在这点上是对的。拉丁裔工人会在凌晨2点排队申请工作。等到当地工人出现时，工作已经被占用了。
And the companies got pickier. Plants added a three-strikes policy, and they tried to stick to it. That if you quit three times, they weren't going to hire you again. The old mirror-test days were over.
而且公司变得挑剔了。工厂增加了“三振出局”政策，他们试图坚持下去。如果你辞职三次，他们就不会再雇佣你了。旧的“镜子测试”时代结束了。
You could sum up the last quarter-century at the Albertville chicken plants this way. Chicken boomed, foreigners arrived, and wages didn't grow-- at least for Pat and Martha-- even though poultry companies made huge profits during the boom. Again, here's Pat.
你可以这样总结阿尔伯特维尔鸡肉加工厂过去的四分之一个世纪。鸡肉业蓬勃发展，外国人来了，工资却没有增长——至少对于帕特和玛莎来说是这样——尽管家禽公司在繁荣时期获得了巨额利润。再次，这是帕特。
You got to realize, I've been there 44 years-- this May, 44 years. And I'm just now making $11.95.
你必须意识到，我已经在那里44年了——这个五月，44年了。我到现在才赚到11.95美元。
You've been working there for more than 40 years, and you're at $11.95.
你在那里工作了40多年，你每小时只有11.95美元。
Mm-hmm.
嗯。
Have your wages kept up with your cost of living?
你的工资跟上了你的生活成本吗？
Lord, no. No. It's amazing, 40 years ago, I could go to the grocery store with $20 and buy groceries and feed a family of four.
天哪，没有。不。这很神奇，40年前，我可以带着20美元去杂货店买杂货，喂饱一家四口。
And what about now?
那现在呢？
Now it takes $120 a week just to feed a family of three.
现在每周需要120美元才能喂饱一家三口。
She makes around $25,000 a year. If her wages had simply kept up with inflation, and she made the same thing as she did back when she started on August the 13th, 1973, she'd now be making $48,000 a year-- basically double. Also, back then, she says she didn't have to pay for her insurance. But now she does. And those costs go up every contract.
她一年赚大约25000美元。如果她的工资仅仅跟上了通货膨胀，她赚的钱和1973年8月13日刚开始时一样多，她现在一年将赚48000美元——基本上翻了一番。而且，那时她说她不需要支付保险费。但现在她必须支付。而且这些成本在每份合同中都在上升。
But how much of the stagnation in her wages is because of immigrants? The economist we talked to, Giovanni Peri, pointed out to us that it's not just Pat and her coworkers in Alabama who've taken this horrible hit to their wages.
但她的工资停滞不前有多少是因为移民呢？我们交谈过的经济学家乔瓦尼·佩里向我们指出，这不仅仅是帕特和她在阿拉巴马州的同事在这段时间遭受了工资的严重打击。
Not just their wages have stagnated in this period. The wage of low-skilled workers, they have a downward trend actually since 1980.
不仅是他们的工资在这期间停滞不前。低技能工人的工资，事实上自1980年以来一直呈下降趋势。
This is all across America. And not just people without a high school education. It's about half the country whose wages have stayed flat or dropped when you account for inflation. The people without a high school degree like Pat have taken the worst of it. There's been a massive transfer of income to managers and shareholders and people at the top of the economic ladder thanks to automation, a low minimum wage, foreign trade with places like China, the decline of unions.
这在美国各地都是如此。而且不仅仅是没有高中教育的人。当你考虑到通货膨胀时，约有一半国家的人工资保持不变或下降。像帕特这样没有高中学历的人遭受了最坏的情况。由于自动化、低最低工资、与中国等地的对外贸易、工会的衰落，收入大规模转移到了管理者、股东和处于经济阶梯顶端的人手中。
Nationally, the meatpacking unions have been losing power since the '60s. A few years back, a sociologist named Jackie Gabriel researched which came first in the meatpacking industry-- wage stagnation or immigrants. She found that it went like this. Back in the '60s, the meat industry restructured in ways that weakened the unions.
在全国范围内，肉类加工工会自60年代以来一直在失去权力。几年前，一位名叫杰基·加布里埃尔（Jackie Gabriel）的社会学家研究了在肉类加工行业中谁先出现——工资停滞还是移民。她发现它是这样进行的。早在60年代，肉类行业以削弱工会的方式进行了重组。
That led to pay cuts. And those pay cuts made the jobs way less attractive to American workers. And that paved the way for immigrants to come in and take those jobs. In other words, it wasn't immigrants that led to wage stagnation but the other way around.
这导致了降薪。而那些降薪使得这些工作对美国工人来说吸引力大大降低。这就为移民进来并担任这些工作铺平了道路。换句话说，不是移民导致了工资停滞，而是反之亦然。
But that still leaves a question. And that is, did the massive arrival of immigrants in the '90s and 2000s all over the country make it worse? After all, in Albertville, it was thousands of people. Did that push down Pat and Martha's wages?
但那仍然留下了一个问题。那就是，90年代和2000年代移民在全国各地的大量到来让情况变得更糟了吗？毕竟，在阿尔伯特维尔，那是成千上万的人。这压低了帕特和玛莎的工资吗？
Well, Giovanni Peri ran the numbers for us. Again, he compared Albertville to counties in Alabama with similar job markets that did not get lots of immigrants. And he found that after 20 years of immigrants pouring into the area around Albertville, the wages of people without a high school education did have a bigger drop than the counties without all those immigrants. Their wages were 7% lower, which works out to--
嗯，乔瓦尼·佩里为我们跑了数据。再次，他将阿尔伯特维尔与阿拉巴马州没有接收大量移民的类似就业市场的县进行了比较。他发现，在移民涌入阿尔伯特维尔周边地区20年后，没有高中教育的人的工资确实比没有所有那些移民的县降幅更大。他们的工资低了7%，算下来是——
$23 per week.
每周23美元。
$23 a week. That adds up to $1,200 per year, per worker. So it's real money.
每周23美元。一年下来就是每名工人1200美元。所以这是真金白银。
When I showed this result to other economists, they said this was not surprising at all. This is usually what studies find. Though in most studies, the change is smaller than this. Most studies of people across the ideological spectrum find that when immigrants like this arrive, the effect on wages is not massive. In fact, it's pretty modest-- just a few percentage points or nothing at all.
当我向其他经济学家展示这个结果时，他们说这根本不令人惊讶。这通常是研究发现的结果。尽管在大多数研究中，变化比这更小。大多数跨越意识形态的针对人群的研究发现，当像这样的移民到达时，对工资的影响并不巨大。事实上，它是相当温和的——只有几个百分点，或者根本没有。
But the people affected are the ones without a high school diploma. These studies show that everybody else in the economy, everyone who's graduated high school or more, either they see no change-- that's what happened in Albertville-- or they see a tiny improvement. The wages go up just a couple percentage points.
但受影响的人是那些没有高中毕业文凭的人。这些研究表明，经济中的其他人，所有高中毕业或更高学历的人，要么他们没有看到任何变化——阿尔伯特维尔就是这样——要么他们看到了微小的改善。工资上涨了几个百分点。
And the one group whose wages suffer, Americans without a high school diploma, that group is not much of the country. It's been shrinking for decades. It's just 10% of adults today.
而工资受损的那个群体，没有高中毕业文凭的美国人，那个群体在全国占比并不大。几十年来它一直在萎缩。今天仅占成年人的10%。
This is why so many economists are always saying that immigration is good for the economy. Because overall, the economy gets a boost. And only 10% of wage earners take a hit. Which, of course, sounds great unless you're in that 10%, like Pat, who didn't graduate high school.
这就是为什么这么多经济学家总是说移民对经济有好处。因为总体而言，经济得到了提振。只有10%的工资收入者受到了打击。当然，如果你在那10%里，就像没上过高中的帕特，这听起来当然不错，但对你是另一回事。
We ran Peri's numbers by her-- his finding that her wages dropped $23 a week-- more than places in Alabama that didn't get all those immigrants. Giovanni Peri cautioned us that $23 a week is the very most the immigrants might have knocked down Pat's wages. There's a big margin of error in this study. So the number might be a lot less, which I told her.
我们将佩里的数字告诉了她——他发现她的工资每周下降了23美元——比阿拉巴马州那些没有接收所有那些移民的地方降得更多。乔瓦尼·佩里提醒我们，每周23美元是移民可能压低帕特工资的上限。这项研究有很大的误差范围。所以数字可能要小得多，我告诉了她。
Worst case scenario, if all that were immigrants, if they cost you $23 a week, and they cost you $1,200 a year, what do you think about that?
最坏的情况，如果所有那些都是移民，如果他们让你损失了每周23美元，让你一年损失了1200美元，你对此怎么看？
Mm. Well, it kind of tisses me off a little bit that they costed me that. But wouldn't it have cost them the same thing?
嗯。好吧，他们让我损失了那个，确实让我有点不爽。但他们自己的工资难道不是也受到了同样的影响吗？
What you're saying is, if my wages went down, then didn't their wages go down too?
你的意思是，如果我的工资下降了，那他们的工资难道没有下降吗？
Didn't theirs go down too? But now, you cannot fault them. You cannot fault a person for wanting a job to feed their family. I don't care who you are.
他们的难道没有下降吗？但现在，你不能责怪他们。你不能责怪一个人想要一份工作来喂饱家人。我不在乎你是谁。
After all these years, it's hard not to notice that there's a symmetry in the lives of the old-time workers like Pat and the immigrants who arrived to work alongside them. Both groups never finished high school. Both groups used the chicken plants as a way to pull their families out of working in the fields. Both are incredibly proud that this is what let them buy a house, cars, send their kids to school, make sure they finished and didn't end up at the plants like them.
多年来，很难不注意到，像帕特这样的老工人和一起工作的移民的生活中存在一种对称性。两组人都没有完成高中学业。两组人都把鸡肉加工厂作为一种将家人从田里工作中解救出来的方式。两组人都非常自豪，因为这让他们能够买房、买车、送孩子上学，确保他们完成了学业，没有像他们一样最终待在工厂里。
And they've both seen their real wages drop over the last 20 years. Carlos has been in the US since the late '70s and sounds very similar to Pat when he talks about this.
而且他们俩在过去20年里都看到自己的实际工资下降了。卡洛斯从70年代末就在美国了，当他谈到这一点时，听起来和帕特非常相似。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语交谈]
The problem is that over the years, we've been getting raises of $0.25, $0.30, even $0.50.
问题是多年来，我们的加薪一直只有0.25美元，0.30美元，甚至0.50美元。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语交谈]
But at the same time insurance goes up. Taxes go up at the federal, local, and state level. And so when you take all of that out, the check stays the same.
但与此同时，保险费上涨了。税收在联邦、地方和州层面都在上涨。所以当你扣除所有这些时，支票上的钱还是一样。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语交谈]
I'm paying more for food, more for the mechanic, and that's what makes my check go down.
我支付更多的食物费用，更多的维修费用，这就是导致我支票缩水的原因。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语交谈]
What we really need is an increase in our wages of $1.00 or $2.00.
我们真正需要的是工资增加1.00美元或2.00美元。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语交谈]
And this brings us back to Jeff Sessions, senator and attorney general, who was the reason that we went to Albertville in the first place. When Sessions explains what he's trying to achieve by limiting immigration, he always talks about working people. He barely sounds like a Republican. Says our system's too biased towards corporations and capital formation and people at the top.
这就把我们带回了杰夫·塞申斯，参议员和司法部长，他是我们最初去阿尔伯特维尔的原因。当塞申斯解释他试图通过限制移民来实现什么时，他总是谈论劳动人民。他听起来一点都不像个共和党人。他说我们的系统太偏向于大公司和资本形成以及处于顶层的人。
And where is it hurting the most? It's the lower-income people. I mean, wages are down from 2000. They're down from 2007. People are hurting. And we need to focus more on the well-being of people who make lower wages-- $50,000 and below.
哪里伤得最深？是低收入群体。我是说，工资比2000年下降了。比2007年下降了。人们在受苦。我们需要更多地关注低工资——50000美元及以下——的人们的福祉。
Thing is, even if Sessions had managed to block immigrants from ever coming to Albertville in the first place, or if the administration that he serves figures out how to do that now, the main things in America driving down wages weren't immigrants at all.
问题是，即使塞申斯成功阻止了移民来到阿尔伯特维尔，或者他所服务的政府现在想办法做到这一点，美国导致工资下降的主要因素根本不是移民。
[MUSIC - "WORKIN' WOMAN BLUES" BY VALERIE JUNE]
[音乐 - 瓦莱丽·琼（Valerie June）演唱的“WORKIN' WOMAN BLUES”]
Next week on our show, we go into town to see what 6,000 newcomers cost taxpayers, and what it was like to have all these immigrants who'd never driven cars before suddenly on the roads not understanding what a stop sign is, and why a Latino business owner told his friend to run for mayor on the platform of kicking out all the immigrants.
下周在我们的节目中，我们走进小镇看看6000名新来者花费了纳税人多少钱，以及那些以前从未开过车、突然上路却不懂停车标志含义的移民是什么样子的，以及为什么一位拉丁裔企业主告诉他的朋友竞选市长，平台就是驱逐所有移民。
Our program today was reported and produced by Miki Meek with additional reporting from Lilly Sullivan, and Diane Wu, and me. Our interpreter was Gabriela Munoz. Fact-checking by Christopher Swetala and Michelle Harris. Original music by Marcus Thorne Bagala.
我们今天的节目由米基·米克报道和制作，莉莉·沙利文、戴安·吴（Diane Wu）和我提供了额外报道。我们的翻译是加布里埃拉·穆尼奥斯（Gabriela Munoz）。克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉（Christopher Swetala）和米歇尔·哈里斯（Michelle Harris）进行了事实核查。原创音乐由马库斯·索恩·巴加拉（Marcus Thorne Bagala）制作。
People who put our show together today include Susan Burton, Zoe Chace, Neil Drumming, Chana Joffe-Walt, David Kestenbaum, Jonathan Menjivar, BA Parker, Brian Reed, Robyn Semien, Lyra Smith, Julie Snyder, and Matt Tierney.
今天参与制作我们节目的人包括苏珊·伯顿（Susan Burton）、佐伊·蔡斯（Zoe Chace）、尼尔·德鲁明（Neil Drumming）、查娜·乔夫-沃尔特（Chana Joffe-Walt）、大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆（David Kestenbaum）、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔（Jonathan Menjivar）、BA帕克（BA Parker）、布莱恩·里德（Brian Reed）、罗宾·塞米恩（Robyn Semien）、莱拉·史密斯（Lyra Smith）、朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）和马特·蒂尔尼（Matt Tierney）。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
Our website, where this week you can nerd out on Giovanni Peri research on Albertville-- with charts-- thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
我们的网站，本周你可以深入研究乔瓦尼·佩里关于阿尔伯特维尔的研究——包含图表——thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由公共广播交易所（PRX）分发给公共广播电台。
Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, for some reason, he has always referred to his employees as chickens and described his own job as--
一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生。你知道，出于某种原因，他总是把他的员工称为鸡，并这样描述他自己的工作——
I have drawed chickens, hung chickens, dumped chickens, pushed dead chickens--
我拔过鸡毛、挂过鸡、倒过鸡、推过死鸡——
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week, with more stories about Albertville and This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周回来，带来更多关于阿尔伯特维尔和《美国生活》的故事。
[MUSIC - "WORKIN' WOMAN BLUES" BY VALERIE JUNE]
[音乐 - 瓦莱丽·琼（Valerie June）演唱的“WORKIN' WOMAN BLUES”]